hi everyone welcome to the highlight
show of class chess international my
name is Santa Barbra Hammond and I'm
going to take you to key moments of day
three
so today two of the players qualified to
the semi-finals Magnus Carlsen
successfully defeated his opponent
Jeffrey shank and was this all
successfully defeated his opponent
Maxime very low profit so Magnus Carlsen
will meet the winner of the match
between Alexander Chris Chuck and Levon
Aronian
and Wes sister will be meeting one of
his countrymen as he will be facing the
winner of a brianna Corona and linear
Dominguez match so let's dive into the
gates and take a look at what happened
today let's start with the match between
Wesley SAW and Maxima telegraph so Wes
to enter the day with a three-point lead
over his opponent but as you mentioned
in a postgame interview that he felt
that Maxim play it a lot better this
time around and he definitely came ready
to to fight and try to even the score so
in this let's jump to move 53 so we have
this rook endgames and we have seen a
lot of routine games in this tournament
a lot of them are very instructive
so Maxime here decides to go rookie five
and we're going to see how this game
ended in a draw how he successfully very
easily makes a try in this position and
the key is to keep checking and
attacking the pawn and not to a lot of
pongo to eat you so in this game
actually Maxine was doing quite well but
did not manage to do anything with it
and had to settle for a drop and let's
jump into our second game so this game
could have really gone in Wesley sauce
paper as in this position he grabbed
upon the maximum sacrifice a pawn kind
of went all out but didn't really
achieve much for it so he plays rook
Seto Wesley that is and he's met with
rook c8 trading down into Queen wishes
to rooks position and we know that two
rooks are supposed to be better than a
queen and if you look at this position
this Knight is not doing amazing as all
these squares are covered but at the
same time this bishop is also blocked by
its own pawns but white is up upon and
here was they made a huge blunder
playing g5 allowing this Queen to come
in
and entering this position we're not we
see that the Queen has a lot of activity
and the game ended in a draw as the
position became quite complicated and
Wesley decided to settle for a try as he
probably got scared of this past punt
and actually it's kind of hard for a
white to make any progress at this point
and so the games and the first two games
and in the new trust the score is the
same Wesley still up three points with
four games to go
so this match actually finished very
quickly it finished before the Magnus
match was even halfway through they did
start an hour earlier but the gabe's
were very fast fast paced as we can see
this game ended with Wesley six minutes
on his clock and with max in five
minutes on his clock so let's move on to
our third game and this was this could
have been the turning point in the match
as Maxim scores his first victory of the
day narrowing the gap between the two
players so in this position again
another root end game and we actually
see why Brooke and games are notoriously
so difficult and why you know you have
to play them out and if even if you
think you're if you're on the winning
side or if you're pressing and you feel
like you're entering the dry territory
you should still play it out because
there's always so many chances okay
so King f5 was played correctly leaving
this pond going for this G after this g7
pun so a real goes back taking the pawn
which was a blunder because after check
now King has to go the other way because
King g6 loses two to have five
check trading the rocks
and now we're seeing that this pan is
just too fast and what gets another
temple in by checking the king and this
pawn is just quitting so just completely
hopeless King and pawn endgame
so instead after King d5 check the route
goes to c4 so f5 fixing the pawn
structure a4 so now the rook is stuck on
the 7 rank defending this pawn so black
really doesn't have any choice but to go
back and forth so he decides to give up
this pawn hoping to get this F pants
because King g6 runs into check and you
cannot do something like this because it
ends in a draw so I king just six was
plates but of course he goes back ruk f7
and now he finds the brilliant move f6
and here was they actually resigned
because this pawn is going to get lost
because if you take with the pawn it's a
double attack now the rule has to
separate for the from the pan and light
will take it and the main issue for
black is this King gets caught off and
if we take with the rook then route d7
winning this pawn and this is going to
be a winning endgame this was a great
result for maximum at sherrilyn graph
and now with three games to go on two
clutch games in the final two games
the score is that gap is narrower as
Wesley is not only two points ahead so
let's jump to our next game where once
again Maxine was doing well and again
this could have been really the turning
point had he won this game because
psychologically it's very difficult to
start with a three point lead
lose two games in a row and really
narrow that gap so let's start with this
position it's a rook seam on this place
and Maximus black root day for rookie
just kind of a funny spot for the rook
to being Bishop d3 and d2 of course
impossible to take this pawn
and the bishop hangs at the very least
so root demon is played and rook c8 and
now we see this huge issue with the back
rank playing rugby 8 attacking this b3
pawn a for Bishop d2 and now we see the
problem with this Bishop here and here a
maximum decisive force a draw with
rookie 2 and giving a perpetual and he
is forced to do it because of this back
rank mate so this was a pretty
heartbreaking result for him as he had
great winning chances in that position
had he not taken the pawn if we go back
to that position and try it just taking
on c3 and going a4 and just playing out
this position attacking the pawn on e4
bringing his king of just try to look
for chances here and let's jump to our
penultimate round so in this game with
the white pieces Maxime gave up a pawn
early on and decided to go into this
down upon opposite color Bishop endgame
trying to drop but there was a tall task
considering there are two pairs of rooks
on the board and that of course favors
the side that's trying to win so see if
I was played Bishop before and what's
the decides to give up his exchange and
we see that black just has way too many
pawns for white to cope with so let's
let me show you the rest of this game
and some funny moment that happened here
so there's not much to talk about like
he's simply pushing the pawns white
doesn't have any penetration squares
with this rooks and like is just simply
winning like it's just going to
basically shove the pawns and win the
game so can't even create a passed pawn
so h5 actually just close all the files
that no way for the rooks to get active
keeps pushing and here the like has a
great choice between pushing c2 or b2
and Wesley thought they're both winning
he actually blundered would be 2 as p2
runs into simply rugby - because of the
pin and you can actually see on video he
literally like face palms and here so
visibly upset you cannot
you get the clip on our social media
channels of San Luis chess club he was
really shaken up by this but being the
brilliant player that he is he still
finds this amazing strike or fruit k1
forcing the trade of rooks it's a Roxy
to rout day 1 is going to run into this
and it's time to say goodbye to this
road
so instead route pc2 is plate trading
this rooks taking another pun and that
we see the problem with putting the
pawns on the same squares at the bishop
and c2 game is over a really nice win by
Wesley so you actually clinch the title
with this because the gap became 3
points because the gap was too big and
he already clinched the title and the
next game was actually just played for a
bonus in the clutch money and I will
just show you the whole game because
Maxine was clearly very jaded and wasn't
in very good spirits to play this game
so this game ended very quickly so T 496
in 45 we have 6 kind of coffeehouse
chess but again Maxine wasn't in the
best of moods so we go for this end game
castles and huge blunder has to take c6
he takes in 647 and resigns 15 move game
I mean at this point it didn't really
matter for Maximus he was already out
but it didn't matter for his opponent
because with this victory Wesley so
actually won a $10,000 bonus as he want
all the clutch money bonuses because the
games that ended in a drop they rolled
over to these games two games 11 and 12
which he wants so he want all the money
so congratulations to Wesley so on a
fine result and qualifying to the
semi-finals
so let's move on to our match between
Jeffrey and Magnus this match was a lot
closer and on day one
Magnus won his first three games with
Jeffrey did win game number five the
clutch game so he was only a point
behind an ox also by the rules
winning the clutch games gives you
advantage in the tiebreak speak if in
case the mattress tight the player who
has one more time I want more clutch
games is going to win the match so even
though Jeffrey was a point behind he
actually had the better tie breaks so
let's jump to move 33 in this position
in this position after Queen moves from
the attack and Magnus blunders and takes
rook a c5 and after take take he's
simply going to lose a piece because
there's no way to do anything about this
situation with this height because 25
runs into a 4 now then the Queen can no
longer support the night the knight
cannot move because it's supporting the
rook and King f8 runs into Bishop h4 and
just impossible to defend everyone so
instead here he goes c4 when it comes
back and now we see that actual the rook
is trapped - so the world champion
resigned and the match was tied with
Jeffrey having the better tie break so
really amazing situation to be in and
this is not something we're used to
seeing from magnets this game ended in a
draw and
it was quite complicated so a lot of
things happened both players had their
chances it's very difficult to really
dive into it in detail in highlight
video so I'm just going to show you key
moment so in this position
Magnus goes 90 feet but instead you can
try his chances with night age for King
g5 is 7 and something like this and it's
hard to say what's going on in this
position according to the ancient
engines why this thing well but I think
it's quite complicated with two pieces
and all these pawns for the torque so I
think objectively it's hard to say that
one of the sides is doing significantly
better but instead he wins 93 the game
went on for a long time and eventually
after a lot of trades after this pawns
were traded the game ended in a draw the
Magnus was actually quite unhappy with
how the game was going so if you're
familiar with the player that Magnus is
he gets very frustrated when he doesn't
win for a long time anyone that was two
games he was still feeling he admitted
he was feeling frustrated both that he
wasn't winning and two that he wasn't
playing well and this is another thing
about Magnus when he's not playing well
even if he's doing even if he's scoring
he still doesn't feel very happy about
it
and in our third game so this was
actually the crucial game and Geoffrey's
rank himself admitted that this was the
turning point in the match because he
said he simply did not recover from it
psychologically and everything went
downhill from for him so in this
position again looks like a draw another
King and king and rook endgame but as I
mentioned it these positions these end
games really need to be played out
because there's just so much room for
error so everything seems fine and looks
like we're really entering dry territory
and King before huge mistake by the
young player after check this trade
c5 c3 and looks like the game should end
in a drive King g6 but g5 and now
unfortunately for Geoffrey he is going
to lose the game and he resigned here in
view of King goes back and like it's
just going to come and take both of
these ponds and just win the game
because the king will be in front of the
pawn and will the pawn will queen so
this was a really heartbreaking moment
and it was very it was very actually
easy to tell that from the next game the
way it turned out because Geoffrey just
lost so easily in a very one-sided game
our very favorite h4 h5 was played and
this is something that's I think all
players welcome because we like seeing
this brute force kind of attacks just
shoving you're a found on the board
opening the H file and trying to
checkmate your opponent so Queen d2 and
I think here Geoffrey maybe felt his
position slowly might fall apart so he
started looking for some kind of
initiative and trying to merit muddy the
waters so he goes if five but
unfortunately this position is just
really rough for him because all his
opponent's pieces are in the attack this
h-file is going to open and the position
is just not whole double at all goes
back castles takes 95 and 95 comes with
a really nice idea of going 97 with the
threat of going Knight f6 and rook age
seven mate as we will seem so the rook
has to move so check another check
Andrew cage font and this checkmate is
actually unstoppable and white and black
has to part with a lot of material to
cope with it but of course they don't
expect that from players of this level
so Jefferies resigned so up next we have
two two clutch games
so what Geoffrey needed was to win one
and to draw one which is of course a
tall task but he did have the tiebreak
advantage so if you manage to do this
then he would win the match so he was
here at the white pieces in the opening
so this
was actually quite uneventful I can
quickly take you to the through the
opening because the game itself lasted
very long but not a lot happened so we
see the session occur of a pad line of
Magnus Carlsen which is successfully
used against Fabiana Khurana in their
World Championship match so we see this
line so the options are either Bishop f6
taking or 95
so taking GF or 95 in immediately this
is another option so Wesley upset for
this line and we see a lot of theory so
I cannot you know really comment on this
because this is a long theoretical line
so we see all of this happen and I think
there was a novelty on around move 25
and I believe this g4 move that we're
about to see was a novelty and Magnus
actually went down the pawn in a rook
endgame and he drew quite comfortably so
up next is our final clutch game with a
win is worth three points at drys one
and a half and share fries in a must-win
situation with the black pieces and we
know that Magnus is one of the best
clutch players winning this very
important last round games and the tie
breaks and you know very good at this
kind of high tense situation so you know
there was a very difficult situation for
a young Geoffrey to be in and
unfortunately he wasn't able to beat
Magnus as come as no surprise it's
Magnus he's one of the greatest players
in history it's a Magnus plays a four
and Geoffrey blunders with Bishop c4 of
course Bishop has to go back but this
position is already very tough as White
has the extra pawn and the bishop pair
instead Bishop c4 is plate hoping for
some tactics route before with a double
attack but now this great move of a five
and the idea is if the knight takes
Bishop here and the route cannot really
go anywhere to keep defending the knight
because F 3 and the route cannot stay on
the for drink
so instead route c4 was plate and after
eight exp six Jeffrey resigned in view
of a proxy five you check and there is
no way for the rook to stop this plan
from winning a really nice finish by the
world champion the deservingly I want
the match and collected the bonus the
bonus of $8,000 in clutch money whereas
Jeffrey collected $2,000 for his clutch
win in round five so tomorrow the
matches between between level Neronian
and Aleksandra Chris cheek and between
Fabiano Khurana and linear Dominguez
will resume and the two there'll be two
qualifiers and two of the players will
go home but make sure you're tuning in
at one o'clock central to check out the
live commentary on us just jumps